how does 2021's mortal kombat
compare to you to the original 95
version
you know i really like the tone of the
95
because we also remember right this is
what 20 years ago
so mortal kombat the actual video game
is known to be campy
right that's part of the culture of the
game
95 definitely leaned into some of that
camp
um whether it was visually some of the
gags even you know throwing out the
catchphrases but it it worked right and
when you fast forward to the 2021
and it feels like it's more inspired by
mortal kombats
um storytelling and lineage but not
really leaning into
one of the things that really makes it
mortal kombat the fact that you're
playing with violence and a little bit
of camp um i also think really the 95
movie the acting was just better there's
a lot more depth i mean you have
shang tsung you know keri hiroyuki
tagawa
his his representation of shangsung is
so
good that they even brought his likeness
to
the 20 um the most recent mortal kombat
11 video game
and so that voice that depth that the
evilness in him and his performance
actually kind of
was the the thing that solidified that
movie
i'm not hating on chinhan's performance
of shang sung in this one
but it just didn't have the same
gravitas i think when shang tsung is
your big bad
and he's kind of one of the big players
on the board that is setting up
all you know everything it it it takes
away from kind of the the epic scale the
movies so those are kind of the two
things that really stuck out
for me when i compare 95 to 2021 but i
did love
how 2021 from the violence aspect stayed
really true to the game
um i'm talking about specific fatalities
that the fans i was like oh my god
and that that's they should be serving
that group too
yeah and some of the settings that we
got to see in this new movie when they
just
they vault us into the pit all of a
sudden we're like oh my god this is
going to be great and then the movie
ends pretty much
but in 95 jacqueline i feel like what
this movie
the new one does is it makes me
appreciate that 95 was so able to hit
that tone that brian was talking about
where
there is going to be campiness and there
there are going to be some jokes and
christopher lambert as raiden
definitely not the most cultural
appropriate casting i've ever seen but
he certainly had fun but he knew when to
be serious as did his counterpart
shang song and it was just one of those
things where i feel like that hit the
more consistent tone
and maybe we took that for granted
because it's a tough one to hit and i
feel like this new one
had some great moments of comedy
particularly with kano
but then it would veer into being so
ultra serious that it almost felt like
it was dragging yeah um
i'll just go ahead and say it this is
what's interesting did
i played mortal kombat 10 which there i
believe was the first
reboot that they did after a long pause
with mortal kombat
like they were doing like like going to
different realms and they were really
like not doing the old school tournament
then mortal kombat 10 came out and they
went just straight old school
you me fight you know what i mean like
it was really it felt like a throwback
this film felt more like an adaptation
of that
new storyline than it did of the old
school franchises so i think that
and that was serious more serious the
blood codes got
way more um elaborate the fatalities got
way more elaborate and so if we separate
the two in that
they're almost adapting different video
games and i think that's the way
it is and if you know anything about the
director simon mccoyd and i know a lot
thanks to mark hoffmeyer
i think that that is the reason why
there is that disconnect between the
original
and this this newer version and and if
cause i played that one more recently
than the old school ones and that's
more what it felt like and the
characters who are elevated are
different
johnny cage is not as elevated in these
new newer ones some of these other folks
that we're gonna meet later but
um yeah i think um they were not trying
to get away from the camp entirely
they just didn't need it to be the whole
movie they centered it in on specific
characters
which is exactly what the video game did
because mortal kombat 10 had this guy
called like the drunken master who was
literally like a drunken video game
character all right show baby
yes and so he burped he threw up he did
it all
thank you i love brian here who's going
to help my my brain that is awards
adult remember the names of these folks
and yeah it's
so that i think is where that disconnect
is and so i won't even fault them on
that
it's great to hear that my road comedian
behavior has finally been immortalized
in a video game yeah
it's very exciting and sort of what
jaclyn's talking about here brian
is is that feel of the two movies
is so divergent in large part because we
don't have that
tournament setting for the bulk of this
movie i mean i
actually said that between godzilla vs
kong and now this new mortal kombat
movie i didn't necessarily need
any humans to have lines or dialogue i
just wanted two or three announcers to
be on the sidelines and just guiding us
through the action like it is an actual
sporting event because
this it was such an easy tournament to
follow in the original and here we are
getting deeper getting into the
storyline
so i guess my question for you is where
does your appreciation for them getting
deeper into the lineage of mortal kombat
and
trying to get involved in these
backstories versus
just having that cool tournament look
was it too much to try to cram all of
that into one movie
well you know the fact that we talk
about how this is kind of like a
character select
a first step of the movie if i look at
it that way
i think they did do a good job trying to
at least develop some of these key
character components
now you know when you talk about from a
tournament standpoint
losing losing that it makes the focus of
the move it makes the entire tone and
the feel the movie
different the stakes just aren't as high
right we're just establishing
a group of individuals trying to figure
out what their kana is
what their power is versus some bad guys
that are saying we're going to stop you
from that versus
this is the battle for the entire future
of
earth realm those are completely
different stakes so i think
that is part of it i do want to go back
real quickly when we talk about even
comparison the tone today
in the past we should even just talk
about comparing the tone of
this movie to the actual video games
because mortal kombat
has an amazing incredible story mode
that everyone that follows the fighting
game genre
understands its depth its breath and
i'll be honest with you i feel like the
voice performances
i'm not even talking about the motion
capture the voice performances from the
games
were better than the performances
of the actors in this movie and i know
they're just getting started they're
probably feeling out their characters as
well
um but that i think as someone who's
like
oh my god the story of the game is so
incredible when the movie can't get
even close enough to that you do feel
like you're missing something as well
you